[Musique]
en mars 2019 et il nous parlait de ses
anges gardiens faut se rappeler qu'il y
a des gens jour 10 ans jour pour jour le
seul lanceur d'alerte américain rendait
publique des informations top secret
classé vraiment au plus haut niveau de
la NSA qui a fait de lui l'un des hommes
les plus recherchés de la planète il
doit se donner de la pub bénéficier de
la protection on les appelle des anges
gardiens des personnes qui ont pu
ensuite venir vivre au Canada c'était
des réfugiés et qui vivaient cacher un
gangs ils sont arrivés ici sauf un qui
est toujours coincé encore alors qu'il a
eu déjà plusieurs autorisations ça
bloque où à Ottawa mon invités
bonsoir maître la première fois qu'on se
rencontre faites nous aujourd'hui c'est
le 10e anniversaire des révélations de
Snowden et le jour même vous déposez un
recours en cours fédéral pour forcer
Ottawa à agir pour que Hadji juste sur
la photo viennent au Canada rejoindre
les autres réfugiés d'angle
effectivement c'est une date aujourd'hui
qui est non seulement symbolique mais
d'abord avant tout c'est un geste qui
est devenu nécessaire
ce qu'il faut comprendre c'est que oui
ça fait 10 ans bientôt que edgeordan se
rencontrer pour la première fois ça fait
bientôt 7 ans que on a demandé que je
dois demander la protection du Canada
en tant que réfugié pour venir
s'installer ici enfin trouver la
sécurité ça fait 20 ans qu'il le fuit
son pays natal le Sri Lanka ça fait 4
ans et demi que le gouvernement fédéral
reconnu qu'il répondait aux critères du
statut de réfugiés et ça fait trois
semaines que le gouvernement du Québec
lui a émis un certificat de sélection et
à renouveler son autorisation à notre
organisme pour le parrainer privément
pourquoi ça bloque maintenant on ne le
sait pas mais ce qu'on sait c'est que le
Bureau canadien divisa qui a demandé au
ministère québécois d'émettre un
certificat de sélection sans teinte à
poursuivre une évaluation de sécurité
qui depuis 73 mois c'est inexplicable et
c'est ignoble qu'est-ce qu'on craint de
la Jet parce que c'est un ancien soldat
ou Sri Lanka il a été détenu torturé
aussi là-bas et s'il y a encore des
portes des réfugiés ou des mandats et là
ils sont soumis ils restent la peine de
mort si il est déporté c'est ce que le
Canada lui-même a dit dans ses notes qui
ont été signés en janvier 2019 dans le
dossier d'adulte on reconnaît le risque
que auquel adjud va faire face le risque
de peine de mort si les retourner au Sri
Lanka après 20 ans de s'être enfui de ce
pays d'avoir fui le pays en tant que
déserteur de l'armée on ne sait pas
pourquoi le Canada traîne dans ces
vérifications d'antécédents dans le cas
d'adulte ce qu'on sait c'est que la
statut on lui donne on reconnaît qu'il
répond aux critères du statut on refuse
toujours de lui émettre le visa parce
qu'on clame sans plus de précision que
des vérifications sont toujours en cours
ce qui est assez surprenant ici l'unique
façon l'unique chose qu'on peut spé à
l'heure actuelle c'est que on dit qu'il
est
on peut présumer que c'est parce que il
a été dans l'armée sri lankaise dans les
années 90 mais c'est non seulement ce
qui est central à sa demande de réfugiés
est devenu un frein parce que oui il
était dans l'armée mais il a subi des
violences sexuelles et il a été torturé
il a été emprisonné il y a une tentative
d'exécution il a fui le Sri Lanka à
cause de ça c'est le moteur derrière ça
demande et aujourd'hui c'est devenu le
frein alors ces gens-là vivaient très
pauvrement très modestement encore ils
ont aidé ce qu'on donne avant qu'il ne
se retrouve en Russie ou les miens je
pense même un résident russe on aimerait
savoir des nouvelles de lui comment il
vit avec ce régime alors que lui défend
la liberté de presse nous donne
dans quel état est-il
adjuda de santé était psychologique
était le gouvernement canadien lui-même
reconnaît qu'il est dans un dans un haut
niveau de vulnérabilité c'est une
personne qui souffre d'un syndrome de
stress post-traumatique en raison de
l'expérience qui vécu
au Sri Lanka c'est une personne qui
était également victime de persécution à
Hong Kong où il a initialement demandé
le refuge il y a près de 20 ans et c'est
aujourd'hui quelqu'un qui a peur de
mourir tout simplement et que le Canada
après avoir reconnu ce risque-là il y a
4 ans et demi après que le Québec lui
est accepté il y a trois semaines qu'on
lui refuse encore ce statut c'est
absolument inacceptable à vivre c'est
grâce au c'est vous qui les David
comment gagner pour les réfugiés Ford
c'est vous qui l'aidez à vivre là-bas
depuis 7 ans on est sa principale source
de revenus parce qu'il n'a pas le droit
de travailler depuis l'an 2003 alors
est-il en contact avec les autres anges
gardiens qui sont arrivés au Canada et
eux comment vont-ils parce qu'on les a
vu sur notre plateau sont venus à 24 60
à l'heure arrivée alors oui il arrive
qu'ils échangent de temps en temps
justement hier je parlais
à deux autres des des anges gardiens ce
qu'on donne qui sont maintenant à
Montréal avec leurs enfants ils ont des
emplois ils ont permis de conduire ils
ont récemment fait un beau voyage à
Ottawa voir les tulipes il s'agit de
famille qui s'intègre très bien dans la
société québécoise les enfants parlent
un français mais alors là vraiment
impressionnant depuis leur arrivée de
Monsieur drinville passez-moi
l'expression non ça existe français ils
sont certainement sur la bonne voie pour
pour y arriver donc on voit que ce sont
des gens qui ont fait preuve d'une
grande résilience c'est une capacité
d'adaptation
accompagner de mettre Thibault qui est
un avocat qui pratiquait encore mais qui
était lui-même la cible de
perception je pense à encore quelle est
la suite maintenant il reste combien
reste combien de temps avant que la
requin soit entendu demander l'anus bah
alors ce qu'on va faire ce qu'on compte
faire c'est justement demander d'être
urgemment entendu par la Cour fédérale
mais encore là c'est encore une question
de délai la Cour fédérale à l'heure
actuelle prend beaucoup de temps rendre
des décisions donc on espère pour le
mieux est-ce que ça se peut que le
recours freine décision ou vous voulez
que ça l'accélère on veut que ça de
l'accélère on l'aurait pas fait
autrement d'accord alors nous au courant
de Snowden des fois
les communications sont toujours
complexes on lui souhaite quand même
merci merci pour voir nos émissions en
entier rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI